foreign
criticism aimed at nvidia's new RTX 4080
but it's important to stress that
there's nothing actually wrong with the
founders Edition we're reviewing today
in terms of its construction features
and overall quality just like the RTX
4090 it's a high quality product created
by a company that's arguably at the top
of its game a firm at the pioneering
Forefront of Graphics technology this is
important to separate the quality of the
product from its pricing which is an
issue and is simply too high even at its
MSRP Baseline and especially so with
some of the third-party partner cards
we've seen okay so the new 4080 is a
good chunk faster than any of the prior
Nvidia ampere offerings including the
RTX 1390 TI but the performance boost
doesn't always correlate with the price
being charged to the point where there
are even data points to suggest that the
15.99 RTX 4090 actually offers a better
deal the founders Edition we're looking
at today arrives same packaging as the
RTX 4090 and it has the same excellent
chassis the only difference is that
while the same controversial 12 volt
power socket is on the card this time
you get a dongle adapter with just three
eight pin pcie inputs that's still more
than enough though bearing in mind that
the power hungry RTX 3090 TI shipped
with the same adapter the uniform design
across both Ada Lovelace cars also means
that you're getting the same video
options one HDMI 2.1 and 3 DisplayPort
1.48 ports here you can see how the RTX
4080 compares to its Flagship partner
and the upcoming uh well I guess it's
the 4070 TI yet to be confirmed but it's
fair to say that the cutbacks from 40 90
to 4080 are big wider and deeper than
the specs differential we saw between
RTX 3090 and RTX 3080 they're using
different dies for starters you're
getting around 59 of the compute power
73 of the memory bandwidth and
two-thirds of the vram and yet you're
paying 74 of the cost price of the
flagship so realistically you should be
expecting at least 74 of the RTX 4090s
performance and ideally it should be a
lot more as users expect a better price
versus performance ratio the cheaper the
product gets right in fact let's lay out
exactly why pricing is such an issue
with this card the Baseline cost of RTX
4080 is 11.99 US Dollars while its
predecessor had an equivalent 699 us
MSRP roughly a 72 percent increase in
cost gen on gen however of all the top
end cards of the last generation only
the RTX 3080 was reasonably priced
here's a performance snapshot showing
RTX 3080 against the 1119.3080
AI the
1499.3090 and the hilariously priced two
thousand dollar Thirty ninety TI all
based on the same chip but everything
from the 3080 TI upwards simply does not
offer the same kind of value as RTX 3080
so RTX 4080 is faster faster even than
3090 TI by a decent margin it also has
features last gen won't have enormous
improvements to the media engine
including dual av-1 encoders the optical
flow generator that makes DLS S3
possible but ultimately it's all about
gaming performance right and to make
pricing work you kind of have to ignore
that the RTX 3080 the 4080s predecessor
actually existed and that's before we
factor in the 4090 which adds further
pressure to 4080 pricing as we shall see
in terms of just how much faster it is
and on top of that there's further
pressure from amd's rdna3 offerings
which in value terms at least are also
going to cause anything your problems if
amd's marketing claims hold up we'll get
on to game performance shortly but let's
quickly cover gen on gen efficiency
Energy Efficiency varies according to
the game you are running of course but
if we Stack Up Performance against Power
consumed which is exactly what we've
done in this table here in all cases the
RTX 4080 reports power consumption
beneath its 320 watt limit and compared
against prior 80 class cards they're a
sizeable efficiency advantages put
simply frame rates are considerably
improved gen on gen and especially when
you're looking at RTX 3080 there the
performance Advantage doesn't result in
much of the way in increased power
consumption in fact as you'll see the
RTX 4080 can deliver both a performance
boost and a reduction in power
consumption simultaneously in some
workloads let's talk game performance
specifically where we pair the new wave
of gpus with a core I9 12900k and 32
gigs of 6000 Mega transfers per second G
g-skill ddr5 we've completely revised
our test bench to better reflect the
future of gaming technology that means
we're zeroing in on titles using key
engines and low-level gaming apis while
we've beefed up representation for Ray
tracing and image reconstruction
Technologies we're acknowledging that
higher Fidelity via raid facing is a key
feature of today's games while also
understanding that most people will be
using Technologies like dlss or fsr2 to
maximize performance while retaining
those features but first of all I wanted
to clear up something bizarre from some
Nvidia marketing I saw that really had
me worrying about the RTX 4080
this bar chart seems to suggest that
native 4K performance for a plague tail
Requiem sees the RTX 4090 outperformed
the 4080 by around 93 percent
the good news at least is that my
testing shows are more narrow and more
plausible deficit this section from the
beginning of the game actually causes
frame drops on Playstation 5. we can
assume it's quite demanding here at
Native 4K the 1490 outperforms 4080 by
around 36 percent not 93 thank God using
dlss2 that 36 drops to around 28 this
title also supports dlss3 frame
generation and in combination with dlss2
quality or performance modes the gap
between 4080 and 4090 widens again to
about 33 or thereabouts I'd consider
this differential to be more normal
based on a non-rt workload so my initial
worries about the RTX 4080 based on
nvidia's own numbers can be ruled out
now if we look at performance more
generally it's typically the case that
benchmarks coalesce around certain
figures and gpus are often described in
reductive terms like for example RTX
3080 TI is 10 faster than the 3080 or
whatever but as we'll see there's quite
a bit more variation this time and the
RTX 4080s relationship with the 4090 is
more complicated than I expected I'm
going to be focusing on 4K performance
for this one because anything lower
leads to results that can be influenced
by CPU limits depending on the title
1080p testing basically a waste of time
I'm also going to start with rt
performance because this is where the
latest generation of gpus are truly put
through the ringer this is cyberpunk
2077 in its ultra high RT mode using a
developer test sequence this is the full
monty short of the psycho raid facing
setting but still a hefty workout the
issue here with the RTX 3080 trending
under 3080 TI is seemingly down to a
lack of vram the RTX 4080 Powers ahead
beating the similarly priced 3080 TI by
37 at 4K my first takeaway though is
that perhaps disappointingly RTX 4080 is
closer to 3090 TI performance than it is
to the 4090 RTX 4090 is almost 41 faster
than the 4080 yet costs 33.3 percent
more based on us msrps now point is
value should be increasing as we go down
the GPU stack not decreasing the trend
of RTX 4090 offering performance uplifts
higher than the difference in MSRP
persists here in our second demanding
raid facing test Dying Light 2. this
time that 33 increase in cost is
delivering almost 45 of extra
performance 35 to 36 increase in
performance there for 4080 up against
RTX 3080 ETI that's pretty impressive
and this does rise to 53 up against the
card's notional predecessor the RTX 3080
10 gigabyte version but here's the thing
you're paying an extra 71 72 percent for
that 53 Point boost this is the primary
issue facing the RTX 4080 performance
doesn't rise in line with this MSRP
based on its notional last gen
equivalent while the more expensive card
is once again offering a superior price
versus performance ratio
the value issues facing the RTX 4080
Abate just attaching codemasters f122
here benched at maximum settings with a
full range of RT features enabled so
here 4090 costs 33 more but it's
delivering around 37 more performance
that's one pressure point perhaps
partially alleviated but the fact
remains that once again you're paying a
lot more money versus the 3080 that
you're getting in terms of a frame rate
upgrade gen on Gem and only by comparing
against the overpriced RDX 3080 ti do
you get any notion or increase in price
versus performance
over to our control Test Now High
settings High rate racing hosted in Alex
battalion's Corridor of Doom a known
pressure point in the game this causes
all manner of problems as you're only
getting a 39 Improvement in performance
against 3080 dropping to just 22 points
against 3080 TI what's concerning here
though is that whatever pressures are
facing the RTX cards here the 4090 seems
to be somehow immune I had to test and
retest this one but it seems that here
the 4090 Flagship is around 48 faster
than RTX 4080 it's a result that only
makes the halo product more attractive
bizarrely offering much more value the
glacier engine from i o interactive
takes no prisoners with its Ray tracing
implementation and in common with all
the titles tested so far I guess
realistically you'll be using an
upscaling solution like dlss to player
though to be fair Hitman 3 here supports
dlss fsr2 and xcss but in terms of pure
RT performance the same kind of
pressures on 4080 come into play here
ultimately the RTX 4090 is punching
above its weight up against 4080 in
terms of price versus performance with a
nion 46 percentage Point increase and
once again you're seeing a performance
uplift against the 3080 not in line with
the cost increase it's still around 52
percent faster though at the risk of
sounding like a broken record it's only
a comparison against the RTX 3080 TI
that paints RTX 4080 in a good light
4080 ends up with an appreciable 38 lead
onto Metro extras where the revised 4A
engine is built around raid facing as a
foundational concept for its stunning
real-time Global illumination system
it's a showcase technological
achievement for the current generation
of consoles that only gets better on PC
where 4A doubles down on further visual
Fidelity tessellation hybrid RT
Reflections and more the game works fine
on AMD gpus but delivers vast
improvements to performance on Nvidia
cards this is an interesting example of
where the performance differentials for
the 4080 up against 3080 and 3080 TI
remain pretty much as expected at 50 and
39 respectively but this time RTX 4090
does not scale quite so highly its lead
is down to 36 in this title ultimately
though the new RTX 4080 still delivers
frame rates closer to 390 TI than it
does to RTX 1490
onto a Marvel Spider-Man remastered now
another game laudable for supporting all
upscaling Technologies including
insomniac's own software solution and
yes there's even DLS S3 functionality as
you saw in our 4090 review and bespoke
dlss3 coverage with this title RTX 4080
falls into the same category of
performance seen in Metro Exodus
enhanced Edition in that the Gap closes
up against 4090 which commands a Circa
36 percentage point lead over 4080.
however the very high RT preset seems to
max out the 3080s 10 gigs of memory
resulting in a performance degradation
that sees the 4080 pull ahead by 63
percent the Gap closes to just 31 when
stacked up against RTX 3080 TI where 12
gigs of frame buffer memory seems to
comfortably contain the game's
requirements we've delivered a big bunch
of metrics revealing the rate-facing
power of RTX 4080 but let's be honest
engaging RT is typically accompanied by
the use of second generation upscalers
like dlss fsr2 and xcss so it's worth
benchmarking these Technologies working
in concert it's not factoring in image
quality mind you where Nvidia enjoys a
noticeable Advantage which is talking
about raw performance here we choose
titles here that only support dlss and
fsr2 though in terms of competitive
analysis when considering a GPU purchase
remember that there are many more dlss
games than there are fsr2 titles in fact
the vast majority of RT games support
dlss and right now the same can't be
said for any other upscaling technology
returning to Marvel's Spider-Man
remastered we actually find a game where
the new generation of gpus are so fast
you may not even need upscaling the
results here are fascinating because
4090 only commands a small 10 to 11
percentage point lead over for the 4080
in 4k dlss performance mode and this is
because the game runs so fast we're
hitting the CPU limits of the core I9
12900k we get close to it with RTX 4080
while RTX 49t slams right into it so I'd
recommend dlss quality mode or even dlaa
on this one for the higher tagbus
depending on whether you're gaming on a
4K 60 hertz or higher refresh rate
display interestingly the 3080s
performance deficit disappears here
presumably upscaling from 1080p via dlss
alleviates the pressure on the 10
gigabytes of frame buffer memory
returning to our cyberpunk Benchmark
based on an internal test sequence used
by CD projekt Red and quite different
from the standard Benchmark well the gap
between RTX 4080 and 3080 remains wide
at 56 but it's interesting to see the
RTX 1490s performance differential
reduced from Circa 40 at Native 4K to
just 27 in the mode people are more
likely to actually use could we be
hitting the CPU limit here perhaps up
against the 3080 TI 4080 still delivers
a decent enough 32 percentage point lead
Dying Light 2 one of the most demanding
RT workloads there is also benefits a
lot from dlss as you might imagine a 57
increase up against RTX 3080 dropping to
a still impressive 42 point lead over
3080 TI once again a big performance
lead for the 4090 at Native 4K drops
significantly with dlss performance mode
active it's around 33 percentage points
to the better bringing it into line with
its price point just a reminder though
we should be seeing value increase as we
go down the stack not decreasing or even
sitting static as is the case here
remember the RTX 4090 is effectively a
standalone Halo product with an extreme
price tag and 4080 pricing shouldn't be
normalizing that as some kind of new
standard
so far it's not been the best start for
the RTX 4080 we've seen appreciable
gains against 3080 and 3080 TI but the
gains against the non-ti Ampere card are
not in line with the price increase and
that's problematic meanwhile key titles
have revealed that the RTX 4090 actually
offers better value in some scenarios
despite its monstrous cost that changes
now as we move into rasterization
benchmarks where the 4080 is much much
closer to its bigger brother however
there may well be an argument here that
the Ada Lovelace Flagship is actually
being held back by the CPU in a way that
the RTX 4080 may not be something to
bear in mind looking at remedies control
we do test a different area of the game
compared to the RT Benchmark but even so
the 4090s massive lead is cut down to
less than 30 overall suddenly the price
performance ratio between the two cars
shifts attach in favor of RTX 4080.
though remember as I just said value
should scale higher as we go down the
GPU ladder however at the same time RTX
4080 is still not living up to its price
when compared with results from the 699
RTX 3080 the new card is about 43 faster
but costs 72 percent more
a 27 increase in frame rate over 3080 TI
also Trends under other results we've
seen so far
4K rasterization tests in cyberpunk 2077
reveal performance that isn't a world
away from the ultra high RT preset for
the ad scores 42 frames per second here
on average up against 33 with all the RT
bells and whistles enabled so I'd
venture to suggest that optimized
settings would be preferable here as
well as the use of dlss regardless once
again RTX 4090 doesn't scale that well
against the new 4080 with just a 22 lead
and it's not the CPU that's the problem
there there are scaling problems across
the board with this one the performance
gains offered by the new Ada Lovelace
card up against 3080 and 3080 Tio around
10 percent off the pace at around 42 and
23 respectively not great
do maternal is an interesting example of
scalability when the top tier GPU in the
lineup is actually too powerful for the
CPU it is paired with and we're using
one of the fastest on the market with a
53.5 percentage boost up against RTX
3080 and a 41 Point uplift versus 3080
TI the card returns to its more familiar
performance profile however RTX 4090
just 21 faster than 4080 and when you're
talking about a Circa 296 frames per
second average in this sequence we can
be reasonably sure that the CPU is
influencing and degrading the 4090s
result gears 5 is our sole Unreal Engine
4 representative for GPU reviewing
because it's one of the few titles on
the engine that does not stutter a 54
point lead over RTX 3080 dropping to 33
over 3080 TI 4090 is about 31 of the
better here so thus far rasterization
tests seem to have blunted the 4090s
advantage over 4080 but Hitman 3 reminds
us that it's still there in some
scenarios even with no raid facing
involved RTX 490 still manages to
deliver a 47 percentage Point
improvement over the RTX 4080 in this
Dubai Benchmark tellingly though the
performance differentials between 4080
and the 3080 and TI models are from the
last generation remain roughly in line
with Trends seen in other tests at 46
ahead of 30 80 and 34 ahead of 30 atti
just a few more tests to go before we
wrap up kicking off with Forza Horizon 5
where the results with RTX 4080 looking
down towards older generation Parts
reveal the same kind of performance
differentials we've come to expect so
nion 48 percentage Point boost to
performance over RTX 3080 dropping to 36
versus 30 ATT I the RTX 4090 only gets a
24 percentage Point upgrade over the
4080 but we can be reasonably sure here
that's a limit imposed by our CPU not
the graphics Hardware
4090 really is a performance Beast onto
the rage engine now with Red Dead
Redemption 2 the RTX 4080 falls into
line with expectations when it comes to
comparisons up against 1490 in non-rt
workloads at least essentially with the
flagship an extra 33 of Cash Money
translates into a Circa 30 of extra
performance though again we should be
expecting better value Downstream from
the Halo product however the already
problematic pricing for the RTX 4080
comes into an even sharper focus when
stacked up against prior offerings such
as 3080 and 3080 TI where users get just
a 36 and 24 uptick in performance from
3080 and 3080 TI respectively this is an
outlier more generally but still
strongly indicative of a product that
isn't sitting at its natural price point
finally Shadow the Tomb Raider the
flagship 4090 Trends above average with
a 39 uptick over 4080 but elsewhere
there were a few surprises a 51 boost
over the RTX 3080 dropping to around 34
up against the 3080 TI okay so those are
the numbers Mason but what about the
takeaway
when Nvidia first announced the RTX 4000
line of graphics cards it did so by
unveiling a vision of the future for PC
gaming Graphics Innovations in terms of
both software and Hardware that offer
exceptional increases to Performance in
the here and now and effectively laying
the groundwork for a new paradigm for PC
graphics going forwards pretty amazing
stuff but the results have been mixed on
the one hand RTX 1490 is one of the best
Halo products we've ever seen delivering
astonishing performance it's expensive
but it does something we've never seen
before and it's pretty awesome meanwhile
DLS S3 looks like a highly promising
technology but it still requires a bit
more work in terms of ironing out some
of its issues the point is though that
it's a net positive an enabler to
improve experiences for PC gamers
however the missteps of the RTX 4000
launch have only been partially
rectified all of the good stuff that
Nvidia revealed in its announcement was
overshadowed by the pricing problems the
RTX 4080 12 gigabyte model May well have
been quote unquote unlaunched but this
does not address the fact that the one
through RTX 4080 remains significantly
overpriced in terms of price versus
performance it's overpriced compared to
its direct predecessor the RTX 3080
which delivers two-thirds of the
performance for just 58 of the RTX 4080s
cost it's overpriced compared to the RTX
4090 amazingly enough which can actually
show an improvement in price versus
performance when the opposite should be
true it's also rewriting the rule book
in a way that simply doesn't make sense
to the consumer typically the more
higher ends the GPU the lower the price
performance ratio tends to be conversely
the lower down the stack you go the
better the deal you're supposed to get I
don't think that the RTX 4080 is
delivering that those looking for a
slightly cut down RTX 4090 with a decent
discount are obviously going to be
disappointed and in fact the 1199 us
price point leaves little room for an
RTX 4080 TI based on the top end silicon
a cut down 4080 TI at say 1399 us makes
no sense when the full model the full
RTX 4090 would cost just 14 more
so you could stick with discounted
ampere cards instead and all of the ga
102 products from 3080 upwards are still
great gpus alternatively you can wait
for RX 7900 from AMD but even here we're
seeing the Radeon team deploy the same
strategy as Nvidia keep prices on the
highest end card static but increase
prices on cards that should be offering
more value the Gap in specs between 7900
XTX and 7900 XT is actually wider than
the gap between 6900 XT and 6800 XT but
in amd's case the 7900 XT costs 38 more
seems to me like flagships are staying
where they are but prices are being
hiked on low end cards and amd's only
saving grace is that it's cheaper
overall than Nvidia difficult times
ahead I'd say but it certainly would be
easier to recommend the 4080 if it were
a thousand dollar car but even then
that's still a hefty price increase gen
on gen and only maintaining status quo
in terms of price versus performance
versus RTX 3080. summing up then I have
no hesitation in recommending RTX 4080
as a product as a great piece of
technology but the current pricing makes
little sense with the founders Edition
reviewed here that's a shame because the
experience delivered by the products is
pretty great 4080 might not have quite
the same wow factor as the 4090 but it's
still highly impressive however the
price premium is difficult to justify
with pressure coming from so many
different directions so that's the end
of this Mammoth review please like
subscribe share if so inclined and ring
the bell for those notionally instant
notifications DF supports a program join
us for high quality video downloads of
everything we do early access to a ton
of videos bonus material brilliant DF
retro content and so much more but
that's all from me for now thanks for
making it all the way to the end of this
huge video if indeed you did and uh just
generally thanks for watching and
supporting digital Foundry
[Music]